>>THIS MORNING AN ANSWER CERTAIN TO ECHO
AROUND DONALD TRUMP'S ORBIT
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE.
NOSAYING YES BUT NOT SAYING NO
TO ANSWERING JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS.
>> IF THEY WERE TO CALL YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE, TO COME AND
TESTIFY, WOULD YOU BE AGREEABLE?
>> I WOULD -- IF THERE WAS AN
INVITATION TO PARTICIPATE, I
WOULD CONSIDER IT.
YOU'VE HEARD ME MENTION THE
CONSTITUTION A FEW TIMES THIS
MORNING.
IN THE CONSTITUTION WE HAVE
THREE CO-EQUAL BRANCHS.
ANY INVITATION BEING DIRECTED TO
ME, I WOULD HAVE TO REFLECT ON
THE UNIQUE ROLE I'M SERVING IN
AS VICE PRESIDENT.
IT WOULD BE UNPRECEDENTED IN
HISTORY TO BE SUMMONED TO
TESTIFY ON CAPITOL HILL, AS I
SAID, I DON'T WANT TO PREJUDGE.
IF EVER ANY FORMAL INVITATION
RENDERED TO US, WE WOULD DUE
CONSIDERATION.
>> IS THAT A NEWLY COOPERATIVE
SURE?
OR IS IT I'M BEING POLITE BUT
YOU GOT MY CHIEF OF STAFF, MY
CHIEF COUNSEL, WE'RE GHEERD?
>> YES.
THAT'S A VERY LONG, VERY CAREFUL
WAY TO SAY "NO THANKS."
>> NO THANKS.
>> THE WHOLE END OF HIS ANSWER
ABOUT THE CONSTITUTION, UMM,
WE'RE TOLD IT IS -- AH, THE PART
OF THAT ANSWER TO LOOK AND
LISTEN TO.
THERE IS NO CHANGE IN HIS
STANCE.
HE DOES NOT FEEL THE NEED TO
TESTIFY AT THIS TIME, ACCORDING
TO SOMEBODY CLOSE TO HIM.
>> AND CLASSIC MIKE PENCE, BY
THE WAY.
A LOT OF WORDS BUT YOU ACTUALLY
SAY NOTHING.
IT'S A CLASSIC TECHNIQUE HE
USES.
>> YEAH.
AND, YOU KNOW, HE SAID, SURE,
I'LL CONSIDER IT.
THE BUT PART WAS LONGER THAN,
YOU KNOW, THE IDEA HE WOULD
CONSIDER IT.
>> BUT THERE WERE SIGNIFICANT
WORDS, ESPECIALLY AT THIS MOMENT
WHEN YOU HAVE THREATS AGAINST
FBI AGENTS, THREATS AGAINST THE
FEDERAL JUDGE WHO SIGNED OFF ON
THE SEARCH WARRANT AT
MAR-A-LAGO, YOU HAVE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS TALKING ABOUT WAR,
YOU HAVE MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE
IN FCONGRESS SAYING DEFUND THE
FBI.
YOU HAD AN ATTACK IN CINCINNATI.
A MAN ARRESTED IN PENNSYLVANIA
FOR THREATS ON THE FBI.
MIKE PENCE SAID EVERYBODY CALM
DOWN AND WATCH YOUR WORDS.
>> I WANT TO REMIND MY FELLOW
REPUBLICANS, WE CAN HOLD THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THE DECISION HE MADE WITHOUT
ATTACKING RANK AND FILE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL AT THE
FBI.
THESE ATTACKS ON THE FBI MUST
STOP.
CALLS TO DEFUND THE FBI ARE JUST
AS WRONG AS CALLS TO DEFUND THE
POLICE.
>> THOSE ARE IMPORTANT WORDS,
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE MOMENT AND
THE THREAT AGAINST HARD WORKING,
HONEST PEOPLE.
WILL REPUBLICANS HEED THEM?
>> MAYBE OR MAYBE NOT.
THE FACT HE PLANTED THAT FLAG
INTENTIONALLY IN A SPEECH IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE WHERE IT IS A PLACE
WHERE HE MIGHT BE VISITING A LOT
MORE, IF HE DECIDES TO RUN AND
POTENTIALLY CHALLENGE HIS FORMER
BOSS.
HE'S TAKIE STAKING OUT A PLACE
WHERE YOU TAKE A STEP BACK AND
THINK ABOUT THE NONTRUMP
REPUBLICAN PARTY, THE PARTY HAS
BEEN AND SHOULD BE, IF THEY'RE
STICKING TO THEIR IDEALS AND
THEIR FLPHILOSOPHY ABOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT SHOULD BE.
HE KNEW WHAT HE WAS DOING.
HE WAS SEPARATING HIMSELF FROM
DPLUMP -- DONALD TRUMP IN A
DELIBERATE WAY.
>> AND TRYING TO MAKE SURE HE
DIDN'T SEPARATE HIMSELF FROM THE
TRUMP SUPPORTERS WHO ARE WERE
OUTRAGED ABOUT THE SEARCH.
THAT WAS THE LINE ABOUT MERRICK
GARLAND AND SAYING YOU CAN HOLD
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
ACCOUNTABLE.
YOU CAN DEMAND FULL
TRANSPARENCY.
I'M WITH YOU.
BUT NOT WHEN YOU GO SO FAR RIGHT
TO THREATEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
LITERALLY ENDANGER PEOPLE.
THERE'S BEEN VIOLENCE FROM THIS
KIND OF RHETORIC.
HE'S HAVING NONE OF THAT AND
TRYING TO STEER THE PARTY BACK.
SO WE'LL SEE IF IT'S AN
IMPOSSIBLE TASK OR POSSIBLE
TASK.
HIS TASK HERE IS TO TRY TO
BRIDGE THE DIVIDE AND TRY TO BE
A LITTLE SOMETHING.
>> YEAH.
IF IN SO MANY WAYS, HE'S LIKE
WALKING A TIGHT ROPE IN HIGH
HEELS.
I MEAN, THIS IS JUST A
PRECARIOUS AND NUANCED POSITION
HE IS TRYING TO STAKE OUT
AGAINST SOMEONE, YOU KNOW,
AGAINST THE BASE OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT ISN'T
ABOUT NUANCE.
YOU KNOW, IT'S ABOUT THE
EXTREMES.
IT'S ABOUT PASSION.
IT'S ABOUT EMOTION.
THERE YOU HAVE MIKE PENCE TRYING
TO SOUND RATIONAL AND TRYING TO
SOUND LIKE A STATESMAN.
>> REMEMBER, HE SERVED IN THE
TRUMP WHITE HOUSE.
THERE WAS STORIES IN RECENT DAYS
ABOUT HOW METICULOUS TEAM PENCE
WAS IN COLLECTING DOCUMENTS,
LABELLING DOCUMENTS, MAKING SURE
THE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS GOT
BACK TO THE RIGHT PLACES.
IS THERE A SWEET SPOT?
A MIDDLE GROUND FOR MIKE PENCE?
THIS IS HIS TAKE, AGAIN.
MERRICK GARLAND, WE WANT
ANSWERS.
LISTEN TO HOW CAREFUL THIS IS.
>> CALL ON ATTORNEY GENERAL
GARLAND TO GIVE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE A FULL ACCOUNTING OF THE
REASONS WHY THIS ACTION WAS
NECESSARY.
WE NEVER BEFORE IN AMERICAN
HISTORY -- AS A FORMER PRESIDENT
BEEN SUBJECT TO A SEARCH
WARRANT.
>> HE'S RIGHT ON THE LAST PART.
IT'S UNPRECEDENTED.
HE CALLED FOR A FULL ACCOUNTING.
HE DIDN'T SAY IT'S A
WEAPONIZATION OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
HE DIDN'T TALK ABOUT THE GETS
STAFF POE LIKE MANY OTHERS.
>> HE'S TRYING TO BE
RESPONSIBLE.
AS I WAS LISTENING, I WAS
THINKING ABOUT ONE KEY CHALLENGE
HE HAS THAT NO OTHER POTENTIAL
2024 CANDIDATE HAS, WHICH IS
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO WERE NOT
ONLY THERE ON JANUARY 6th, BUT
ACTUALLY BELIEVE WHAT DONALD
TRUMP SAYS, THINK HE'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR DONALD TRUMP
LOSING.
HE'S SINGULARLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
DONALD TRUMP NOT BEING ABLE TO
GET BACK INTO THE WHITE HOUSE.
THAT'S A BIG CHALLENGE THAT HE
HAS.
>> YEAH.
IT'S TOTALLY MISLEADING.
IT'S NOT TRUE.
THERE'S NO FACTUAL BASIS.
IT'S A PERCEPTION THAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT IS STILL --
>> RIGHT.
HE'S ON THE BATTLE FIELD FROM A
DIFFERENT ANGLE THAN LIZ CHENEY.
NEEDS TO CHANGE A LOT OF MINDS
TO GET ANY TRACTION.
>> RIGHT.
IN LOOKING AT MIKE PENCE, HE'S
SUCH A POLITICIAN, RIGHT.
HE'S AN OLD-SCHOOL POLITICIAN.
REMINDING YOU OF REAGAN IN HIS
MANNERISMS AND THE WAY HE TALKS.
IN SO MANY WAYS, POLITICS IS
SORT OF BEYOND THAT APPROACH TO
BEING A POLITICAL FIGURE.
BUT, LISTEN, HE'S GOING GIVE IT
A WHIRL.
HE OWES MUCH OF HIS STANDING TO
DONALD TRUMP.
AT THE SAME TIME, HE'S GOT TO
TRY TO SEPARATE HIM.
IT'S A TALL ORDER.
>> HE WAS IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
HE HEADS TO IOWA IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF DAYS TO BE AT THE
STATE FAIR.
OBVIOUSLY WE'LL SEE A LOT MORE
FROM MIKE PENCE.
>> YEAH.
HE'S KEEPING HIS OPTIONS OPEN.
>> RENATO, I WANT TO TURN TO
JANUARY 6th AND THE
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATION
TODAY.
WE JUST HEARD FROM FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE.
HE SAID HE WOULD CONSIDER
TESTIFYING IN NT FFRONT OF THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
TODAY AFTER EIGHT HEARINGS I
BELIEVE DO YOU BELIEVE HE WOULD
BE THEIR BIGGEST STAR WITNESS IF
HE DID AGREE TO TESTIFY?
>> I THINK THERE'S NO QUESTION.
THERE'S A REALLY LARGE WEIGHT
THAT COMES WITH THE OFFICE THAT
HE HELD AS THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, AND LET'S
FACE IT.
HE WAS ELECTED AS PART OF THE
TICKET WITH DONALD TRUMP.
HIS NAME WAS ON THE POSTER AND
ON THE BUMPER STICKERS WITH
DONALD TRUMP, TRUMP/PENCE.
THERE'S NO QUESTION IT WOULD BE
A BIG MOMENT AND HIS TESTIMONY
COULD BE POTENTIALLY QUITE
IMPORTANT.
I THINK THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
IMPLICATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
DRAWN REGARDING WHETHER HIS LIFE
WAS THREATENED, IF HE FELT
THREATENED, AND WHAT HIS
CONVERSATIONS WERE WITH THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
IN OTHER WORDS, AS PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS TALKING TO HIM ABOUT
POTENTIALLY, YOU KNOW, CASTING
ASIDE ELECTORS OR TRYING TO SEND
THE ELECTION BACK TO THE STATES,
WHAT EXACTLY DID THE PRESIDENT
SAY?
HOW DID HE TRY TO PRESSURE MIKE
PENCE TO ENGAGE IN UNLAWFUL
ACTIONS.
I THINK THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT
EVIDENCE AND IT WOULD BE
MUST-SEE TV AND POTENTIALLY VERY
LEGALLY IMPORTANT.
>> WE'RE A LONG WAY FROM HIM
ACTUALLY DOING IT BUT SAYING
HE'S CONSIDERING IT IS NOTABLE.
WE ALSO HEARD PENCE TODAY
CRITICIZING REPUBLICANS FOR
ATTACKING FBI AGENTS, AND THOSE
CALLS THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM SOME
TO DEFUND THE FBI.
HE COMPARED IT TO THE CALLS BY
DEMOCRATS TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
I'M SURE THAT YOU HAVE SPOKEN TO
SOME OF YOUR FORMER COLLEAGUES
IN THE PAST WEEK.
HAS THE BUREAU BEEN RATTLED BY
WHAT WE'RE HEARING, WHAT WE'RE
BEING TOLD ARE UNPRECEDENTED
THREATS?
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT THE
CURRENT LEVEL OF THREATS AGAINST
THE BUREAU AND AGAINST BUREAU
PEOPLE SPECIFICALLY, SPEAKING OF
COURSE OF THE CASE AGENTS
INVOLVED IN THE SEARCH AT
MAR-A-LAGO LAST WEEK, THOSE
THINGS AFFECT BUREAU PEOPLE
DEEPLY, AS WELL THEY SHOULD AND
NOT JUST THE EMPLOYEES BUT THEIR
FAMILIES AS WELL.
THIS IS A VERY TOUGH TIME TO BE
DOING YOUR JOB AS YOU ARE
SUPPOSED TO, BUT HAPPEN TO BE
INVOLVED IN CASES THAT ARE
HIGH-PROFILE AND PROVOKING THESE
SORT OF ATTACKS.
I WILL SAY THAT VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE HAS DONE EXACTLY WHAT MOST
POLITICAL LEADERS SHOULD BE
DOING TODAY.
HE STEPPED FORWARD AND LAID DOWN
A VERY REASONABLE AND OBVIOUS
DEFENSE OF THE FBI, AND TRIED TO
GET PEOPLE TO START THINKING THE
OTHER WAY, THAT IS BACKING AWAY
FROM THESE CLAIMS OF VIOLENCE
AND CIVIL WAR AND EVERYTHING
ELSE AND TO START BEHAVING A
LITTLE MORE REASONABLY AND I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT HE MADE
THOSE REMARKS.